last week we answered as many questions
that you gave us about the playstation 5
as we could but we were
under embargo but now we're not so we
can actually answer way more questions
um that aren't just about the dual sense
controller and how the playstation
looks so that's what this episode is
going to all be about we can also talk
about miles morales
as well as more things about astro bot
so joining me to go through your
questions
i've got boost mode jordan remain what's
up
and playstation plus collection hussein
absolutely
ravenous for new consoles lads that just
sounds like you're hungry
i know i'm pretty sure they brought that
one as well
probably the most normal one he's used
well i was gonna say another one which
just grossed me out and i was like no i
can't do that one
i mean hang on what is it evan you can
bleep it out
uh what was it again it was
i think
you should keep this [ __ ]
bleep the word so people will never hear
it
all right let's get in because we've got
so many questions to go through
so first up is creative being a little
cheeky in the comments and apologizing
for the nonsense of the questions last
week
real quick you can tell creative is a
real gamer because he's moaning on the
internet about other people
relax bro you would understand that tam
being a real gamer yourself
we've got the answers we're sorry we
were under embargo we couldn't answer
them but now we can
so how is the ui lucy and tam is the ui
snappy when moving from game to game how
are the ps4 games running so i mean
that's
that's really two questions in one
personally i really like the ui
there is a a lot to like there i think
it's much cleaner
it runs it is very snappy especially
compared to how sluggish the ps4 ui is
running right now um
it can't really talk to the media
section of stuff because that's not
really live yet but in terms of the
games
way easier to filter things in the game
library for example you can now filter
from where you got stuff from and which
platform
it's on but also you can see at glance
where things are installed which is
really useful because
you can't put ps5 games on external hard
drive but you can put all your ps4 stuff
on so you can
set the console to default to install
all your ps4 stuff
on your external hard drive so if you
want to track that down you can either
quickly
sort by ps4 or sort by where things
are kept which is super useful no
folders though
i miss them i miss the folder so much
yeah no folders um
i don't know if that's coming later but
right now it's just a bar of games
the the ui for me i think is it's very
clean
um it feels non-intrusive
um you don't have the thing where when
you press the playstation button it
backs out of the game entirely
which takes some getting used to
actually so um
it's only always like in that ui video
that they put out they said they want to
maintain the focus around the game and
that's very much the case so i find that
situations where i want to go
out of the game entirely i'm pressing
the button and going oh i can't do that
anymore i have to hold the button down
and then it will pop up the menu
it is very very clean and i think it
takes a lot of what you already know and
like shuffles it about and just
streamlines the process a bit more
um moving from the game to game is very
snappy
the the interesting thing will be
whether it stays that way over time
because like the playstation um ui
playstation 4 ui was snappy when it
first came out
right it was perfectly fine it was
moving
and it's similar for the xbox in a lot
of ways and the xbox one was a bit more
disorganized but the playstation one was
good and then over time
as we add things to the console the hard
drive the wear and tear generally gets
used
it started to slow down to the point
where now towards the end of the life
it's close to unusable sometimes so
it's really weird like it is like
borderline frustrating going
back to ps4 now and seeing how sluggish
it is but
i will say that it's so easy to just put
all your ps4
stuff onto ps5 and it like that kind of
leads into the
second part of that question which is
how are ps4 games running
tam what have you got in the background
there
that is bloodborne baby am i playing it
on ps5
you bet i'm not because i don't break
i'm playing the game but that's not
running on a ps5 because i ain't about
that breaking
nba life and getting sued by no no we're
getting out we're good now oh we're good
now actually
you're safe now you're free that is a
youtube video that's a youtube video
that i have
of the bloodborne title screen um but i
am
breaking the magician's valentino
hey hey i had to make the transition to
ensure that i wasn't breaking any rules
and i did it um so yeah i am playing the
game
on on you know the console and
i won't speak to it specifically um
how are ps4 games running is the
question here
and the the answer is it depends from
game to game
like fundamentally the backwards
compatibility utilizes boost mode
so it should make things a little
quicker it should make things a little
cleaner
whether you get like boosts in frame
rate and that kind of stuff
it's game to game for bloodborne for
example
the load times are quicker is this much
quicker they are much quicker going back
to the hunter's dream and out of it is
considerably quicker
which makes for a much better experience
are the frames
like are you getting better frame rate
not really is it any more consistent
i don't think so i played the early
stages of it and
one of the first things even waking up
in you know the clinic yes
yourself goes clinic i it started for a
second
so there's nothing major happening
i will say though like as you know i
believe bloodborne is the perfect game
in every way
you taste you believe that yes um uh
flaws and all
this is quicker the load times quicker
and it's similar for a lot of other
games it's like some games will just
work
you know the loads will be a bit quicker
maybe the frames you'll get a few extra
the stuff that you really is the
meaningful differences come from games
that have been given a
patch specifically to improve in
performance tag me in coach because i
can talk more to that because i captured
a bunch of it yesterday
so i've been playing the ps5 optimized
version of ghost of tsushima because
that
has come up that patch came out earlier
this week or late last week
and honestly so i played the first hour
of the game on ps4 captured it uh max is
currently working on a comparison
then i played it on ps5 and honestly
like it just
looks so much smoother um it looks nicer
it looks a bit crisper
uh on ps5 load times a kind of a weird
one because
even so ghost of sushima when we had it
pre-launched like we had a few codes
early
the load times were nothing then the
game came out and the load times got
longer
and then they got shorter again and now
with ps5 it's like this weird place in
the middle where it's still
quick and actually booting up the game
um
from the very beginning is is feels much
quicker i guess
um than on ps4 but like
i don't know it's like low times is a
weird one with that one but it looks it
looks way
nicer and evan i'll make sure i get you
footage of it don't worry about it
both y'all cheating answering his next
question are you getting better frames
with boost mode before i even ask it so
i guess i'll just
skip to the next one and have you tested
an ultra blu-ray movie
no no i don't have any uh no we're here
i don't have the lord of the rings ultra
hd blu-ray
i think it's in december and um that
will be the only ultra hd blu-rays
that i own um i'm actually surprised you
don't have that
i don't i think it only just came out i
think it only just came out it's coming
out are you even a real fan lucy
do you know any trivia about lord of the
rings at all
when viggo mortensen kicked the helmet
and he screamed because he thought mary
and pippa were dead he actually broke
his toe
there i i do know more the classic
the girls we can play cup you know a
game that was created on set of lord of
the rings don't
you don't want me to go down this road
so let's just move on uh i don't have
any ultra
yeah i i similarly do not have any ultra
hd blu-rays
um so unfortunately i haven't been able
to test that stuff just yet
but we will once we do maybe we'll buy
an ultra hd blu-ray yeah the lord of the
rings
no we're not buying all the rings i am i
pre-ordered it okay
i was talking about it i was talking
about expensing it
i mean that's a great idea i might do
that yeah you should do that you should
be like oh yeah i need this to test
these i need this hundred and fifty
dollars
the fans need to know yeah the phones
need to know they specifically ask
for load of rings to be tested so and
uh last question coming in from creative
how is the 3d audio when using the
headset
come on gamespot okay sneaky right there
at the end
i mean i i get it creative i'm sorry we
couldn't answer these last week but
i just want to say so i have a really
small head
show us the headphones we do call her
lucy peanut head
wow that is absolutely huge
i have a really small head and like
i just don't think i can wear this how's
the 3d audio
the 3d audio is great especially with
miles morales
um and with astrobot it's really cool
and i haven't tried it with like a
third-party headset just yet but i
really dig the playstation headset in
terms of like
it'll plug plug in the little adapter
and it away it goes
it's super useful um and super easy to
just get set up
it's got a lot of things on the side
like a lot of buttons that i don't think
a
all needed to be on the left side
and b they're not really that obvious to
figure out what they are like the only
one that you can really tell
and matt padgett on our team did a
really good review it's like the volume
has like a dot on the side and so that's
an easy way to differentiate it but
everything else is like
a button or a slide and it's not it's
just not easy to tell what each one does
especially if you're like
whenever i'm adjusting anything i have
to take it off as well i think the 3d
audio stuff is nice
i don't know if the games are using it
as well as
sony hyped it up to be like somebody was
like this is going to change the world i
need a
i need a uh would you call it a stencil
of your ears or whatever to make this
amazing
said mark sony but i kind of listened to
it i was like yeah this is
this is fine like it's not changing my
life in any way and
there's a lot of like comparable dolby
stuff that
has been like arresting when you hear it
and you're like oh this is
this is wild like it's tickling my ear
drums and you know
i was gonna say something else but i
wonder if it'll be more noticeable with
the
playstation 5 just exclusive games like
demon souls and ratchet and clients yeah
that's the cross
gen ones i think like a lot of other
things on the playstation 5. the 3d
audio has a lot of potential we just
haven't seen much of it
yet come to fruition spider-man sounds
amazing like when the music is is is
playing and
it's very hip-hop infused soundtrack so
very bassy sounds good
astro boy astro
uh yeah but astrobot is playroom
whatever it's called is is like it
sounds good but beyond that
don't have much use case to use it it's
a nice well-made headset
if you're planning to buy that um and i
guess it's a hundred bucks as well like
yeah um it's pretty decent for what it
does the 3d audio i think
i think is kind of down to developers to
do smart things with it i'm really
hopeful for demon souls
because i'm really hopeful for resident
evil resident evil demon soul spooky
games give them to me
make them make me make me jump scare
you know that kind of stuff giovanni de
la torre
red dead and other last gen game loading
time and how it compares to
xbox i don't know if y'all have had a
chance to compare it to
i assume he means xbox series x
and s and not the one so
this is a kind of tricky question
because
we've been running tests in some
comparisons etc but
loading times obviously game boost is
applied
automatically so improved frame rate
improves stability
but in terms of loading times themselves
sometimes they kind of need to be
optimized
for ps5 and not every
game has had like a ps5 patch just yet
so you like giovanni's using red dead as
an example here
we can't i don't think it's been patched
yet basically no or or there's no
indication it will be patched like some
games of when it will be patched
yeah like it'll work it'll work but
whether it's been optimized for a new
system
until until until the publisher
themselves say it has been
yeah just assume that it hasn't i think
yeah it's it's everything kind of gets
an
underlying kind of bump
but like we said earlier the real like
noticeable differences will come
with games that are specifically patched
for the new console
ps5 and there's not that many
i think if you're comparing like
baseline to baseline like just putting
just playing a game
on ps5 versus just playing a game on
xbox series x
it feels like the series x does a bit
more across the board
um things are a little quicker to get
into the load times are faster
certainly like on some games that we've
done testing on we've got
comparisons up on the site which you can
check out um
but that's not to undersell or oversell
either of these two
like the baseline for me is i just want
those games to work
and they do i'm not upset that they're
not
you know twice as fast and twice as nice
and looking you know
i i'm perfectly for i've been playing
overwatch on a ps4 for many years now
if i can get that same experience on my
new console
great if it loads up quicker even better
same with bloodborne same with red dead
same with everything else
so you won't have a worse experience for
the most part
you'll simply have the same or better
next question comes from brian traynor
and it is a question that i very much
want answered because the
battery life on the dual shock 4 is
garbage but how is the dual sensors
battery it's fine like it's good i think
i think then
the what is it how much they say is it
like 12 hours per charge
that's so much longer than it is much
longer there is a bigger battery
in there according to those tear downs
um so the
but also like the ps5 the dual sensor
controller needs to do more
um it's working with haptics it's
working with triggers
um so yes we get it lucy you've got a
deal sense
i'm trying to use it as a little
mustache okay it does look like a
mustache
well because i was watching back last
week's episode and when i was trying to
show it it was like
way off frame so yeah but
it is it is better um it's much better
yeah i think it charges a bit quicker as
well i think it i think it does i like
honestly i
i'm loathe to comment too much on this
because i haven't run
tests and timed things
um i have like a is it a 20th
anniversary or 25th anniversary
ps4 controller which i've had for like
three
or so years so it's you know definitely
dying a bit the one thing we will say
and this sounds
this is gonna sound stupid or it's gonna
sound like
weirdly chilly but the charging stand is
really good
like i don't know how expensive it is or
how cheap it is
but and i'm not the kind of person who's
like i need a charging stand i'm
perfectly fine just jamming a
usb cable and using it in like that and
leaving it on charge
but this charging stand i feel like is
is very very convenient
in the way that you can just drop the
cons of the controller in there
um if you're one of those people who
ends up buying a charging stand and it's
usually one of those awkward venom ones
where you have to put a thing in so you
can slide it oh yeah
i had one of those i had one of those
and it got annoying after a while
because you've got this i lost the thing
yeah you lose the thing i would like if
you if you can and you have the capacity
to do it like the charging sounds pretty
cool
agent 48 asked
agent 40 the most can you imagine being
agent 48 and just seeing agent 47
asking apparently the most important
question does it
assuming the ps5 sound like an xf84h
is that a plane that's a fighter
a really loud fighter jet it's it's much
quieter and honestly
what i'll do um is
just like i recorded when we were
playing warzone i'll record
the ps5 when it's playing um
miles let's say or what's what's a
i'll say miles because it's a ps5 game
so i can't really show many ps5 games
here sorry
unless i'm showing you a ps4 game but um
it's quiet it's much quieter like i
don't need to put headset on
just to not listen to the game the
console stick on call of duty warzone
yeah but that means i have to get it on
a hard drive only 300 000 gigabytes on
your hard drive required
i'll get for the purposes of this i'll
i'll do call of duty so that's a fair
example
what a sacrifice what a sacrifice well
so this is one thing so the series x
and i michael did some great videos
comparing
the um the time it takes to move games
onto
external storage on series x and they
are like
nothing maybe a minute takes a long time
on ps5
and ps4 let me tell you it's not
quick uh it takes a good few minutes and
the other day i was moving like a bunch
of my
my always-ons i guess you'd call them
like i always have bloodborne downloaded
i've always got
things like control dishonored 2. um
so if you ever see any footage on the
site where you see those games you know
it's you know it's my
um but i was moving them all across and
it was like 30 minutes to move
five it's it's weird because like the
first 10 minutes are the ps5 just kind
of staring at what you want to move just
being like
because nothing changes on my bar like i
was doing it with all my downloads and
it was just not moving and it's just
like
again again like and then it just moves
everything that's the thing i don't want
to comment too much because i haven't
personally timed it
but definitely comparing it to the
videos that michael put up of the series
x and how quick it is to move games
across
takes a while yeah but it's still
improved from the ps4
it's quicker than the ps4 by a computer
it's
longer on the ps4 side it's definitely
short on the ps5 side but it's not the
really really quick transfer that you
would blistering yeah
okay here we are running warzone and now
can you hear that nothing
nothing
ken cook wants to know chuck
[Laughter]
check to see if it has something
resembling quick resume please
test it by running anthem on it
or some older game that had massive load
times i
i don't know if it's worth reinstalling
anthem so there is sorry bioware
doesn't have quick resume it does not
but there is a switcher so if you hit
the playstation button
and then go down it shows you like your
recently played games
so i tried it earlier going between
bloodborne and ghost of tsushima
and uh so i was in bloodborne
hit the switcher it loaded up ghost from
the very beginning
it didn't like put me back into where i
was in the game when i switched it off
last night
then when i used the switcher again to
go back to bloodborne
it was the title screen and i got the
uh uh you didn't quit out properly
thing from bloodborne so uh no not a
quick resume feature
actively like the ps4 i can only have
one game running at a time
so i tested it by loading up miles doing
a jump
quickly quitting out loading up um astro
bots playroom whatever it's called doing
a jump in that and then going back to
miles to see if
it would load back in and continue the
jump animation like you can do
on a lot of xbox series x games and it
doesn't it will
kick you back to the title screen um
having said that you get back in very
quickly
so like you if you get kicked back to
title screen at least for miles like
in there loaded in back into the game
super fast and that's the game that
saves uh auto saves often so it's always
creating those checkpoints
so i was back in the mix very quickly
and this guy val wants to know
how are the download speed for new games
still the same or a little bit faster
also how nice does it look with the
lights off
download speeds vary depending on your
own internet connection right
yeah i can't really comment because i've
got like
reading games it'll depend again what's
your internet do you have
are you doing just wi-fi are you
connecting it hardline like i think it's
going to change i don't really know how
to comment on that one
i don't think i've noticed a particular
difference
anecdotally yeah also anecdotally like
this could be placebo or my
as the ghetto boys would say mine's
playing tricks on me um
it seems like when you turn put it in
rest mode it still downloads quicker as
it was with the ps4
um i had a bunch of games that i was
watching the download on and it took
forever so i turned it off and
when i turned it back on it was like
yeah done
really quickly um so it feels like
whatever
sleepy productivity tech they've put
into that it's working
still sleepy productivity uh and in
terms of how nice does it look with
lights off
um i'll i'll get you a little video as
well but it
kind of looks a little bit scary give me
lights off as in like
in your bedroom in your bedroom okay
shouldn't be playing video games that
way anyway it's bad for you don't do
that no but like
if you put it in rest mode it has um an
orange light yeah
two orange like bands uh inside the
console and it kind of reflects off the
i'm surprised it's orange and not blue
since the playstation's
just mode it's blue when it's on no is
it white is it white
it's white yeah it i think it goes blue
when you turn it on and then it goes to
white
yeah i i honestly kind of like the way
it looks now i've warmed to it way more
especially in vertical standing and
i i like how imposing it is
threatening something threatening
threatening i'm into it a lot
it's just looming over the xbox yeah
with the lights or the lights off like
it's positioned right in front of my bed
as you can see sometimes it can be like
if you wake up in a stupor in the middle
of the night you're like oh what is that
it's just ps5 relax
i feel the same way about my exercise
bike to be fun yeah
it's because it's a you know i don't use
it
just looming over you just put like
clothes on it so it looks like a
hunchback
like a burglar yeah just like hiding in
the corner
all right so those are your questions
about the playstation 5 uh but now i got
some questions
for jordan who reviewed spider-man
miles morales oh yeah i like how you
just kind of sort of remember that i was
like oh yeah i did do that
time is such a flat circle and i can't
remember what i'm doing
how did you how did you find it what
your kind of overall impressions
um what surprised you about the game and
um all that kind of nonsense uh
i will try to be as eloquent as i am
when writing and it's probably going to
fail
but miles morales i i enjoyed it because
it plays a lot like
2018's spider-man and i enjoy 2018
spider-man
so i also enjoyed playing this game like
traversals pretty much the same combat's
pretty much the same until you start
unlocking some of
miles venom attacks and camouflage
and his unique gadgets miles kind of has
a few powers that are
geared more towards a crowd control and
taking out multiple
enemies at once in comparison to peter
so that's kind of how they try to
differentiate it
i don't think it works out as well as
they want it to just because the core
combat of the normal combat that they're
just taking from peters works so well
that you kind of just play
as miles the same way that you played
peter um
and that kind of feels like a missed
opportunity to further differentiate
miles creative style in comparison to
his mentor
but the story oh the story is
so good and there's so many things that
we can't talk about
without like putting a crap ton of
spoiler tags on
uh this video but
anyone who's played like superhero games
before
has watched superhero movies or read the
comics we'll probably
see like the twists and turns coming a
mile away but it's still a
very enjoyable ride i think and the
ways that they've reimagined the
tinkerer is
probably my favorite aspect of that game
yeah i i can't believe that you said
you could see it coming a miles away oh
my god it's ridiculous
i can't believe you said that how long
did it take you to complete
uh it's pretty short i finished the main
campaign in about
eleven hours but they're still playing
sounds like a speed of 11 miles per hour
do you just have a bunch of these just
lined up are you just egging me on
top clearly i'm just like creating them
and then throwing them away because
they're all cracked but i need to get
them out of my system
oh my god yeah i think um so i i did the
main campaign
about 10 or 11 but john luke on our team
was saying it took him
15 hours to get all the hundred percent
of everything
um that sounds about right so which
honestly for me that is
i'm not gonna wade into the length of
games is too long
debacle debacle debate um
but i just thought that was a perfect
linux yeah like especially because it
like it doesn't understand welcome in
any way
the main story is a lot of fun i love
miles i've never
been a peter parker like i i like peter
parker as a character but
he's i've seen so many iterations of him
and like i thought they did a great job
in something i did
with spider-man uh from 2018 but like
miles just feels
he's so sweet i love him that's good
i almost hate pulling this up because
it's like such a sore point and i'm like
i was hoping that i would grow on the
new look for
peter parker after playing a game and
seeing it over and over and i'm like
i can't i can't do it he looks he looks
like such a baby
it's like tom holland he looks like tom
holland
but i i think jordan's and lucy's right
like
the story is for me the main draw in
this and it never outstands welcome it
does some interesting twists on
the the miles morales story and
the music is very good oh it is
as soon as it started playing i'm like
wow i'm already like
invested in this character in this game
yeah this is
ah good is a good game it's a great game
so you can read jordan's uh full review
on the website we'll have a video
version up on the youtube channel as
well so
next week it's console launch week it's
gonna be
a big week and you won't want to miss
generation next
next friday trust me it's gonna be a
great episode
um happy console
week everyone oh may
may your fedex deliveries be swift
and listen
post office also be sweet here's some
advice
just stand outside don't trust them i
i stood outside and i we know various
people who are like yeah the fedex
person i saw him from a window drive
up to the thing and decide they couldn't
be asking and drive away
there's a lot of reasons why that could
happen you know people who are working
in mail or
very busy time yeah stressed just stand
outside make it easier for them
just be like it's me that's mine that's
me that's my name here's my
government-issued id
please give me my new toy all right
thanks everyone for watching we'll see
you next week
bye
[Music]
you